Sarah Mardini faces up to 25 years in prison
for helping other refugees on the Greek island
of Lesbos
I would do it all over again for the rest
of my life.
It’s transformed me from being a refugee
to a rescuer.
She says she was volunteering with a rescue
team in Greece.
On her way back to Germany from Greece, she
was arrested and charged with crimes including
people smuggling, money laundering and espionage.
Amnesty International criticizes the case
as an attempt to criminalize humanitarian
work in a climate that is increasingly hostile
towards migrants and refugees
(The arrest) was shocking, draining.
I was disappointed and heartbroken because
I was ready to leave.
I was looking forward to studying again, and
someone just takes everything from you in
one second.
Sarah spent 107 days in pre-trial detention
and was released on bail.
She then returned to her college in Berlin
I never regret anything I have done and I
know deep inside that I have done that because
I wanted to help people and that’s given
me motivation.
I didn’t do anything illegal because I didn’t
contact anyone directly.
I was just on the shoreline, and our house,
the ERCI volunteer house, was just on the
shoreline.
And I am just handing water and blankets.
Do you think handing water and blankets is
illegal?
No, it is not.
Interviewer: But people say, it is because
they know there is someone waiting, that is
why they come.
If they thought that there was no one.
Sarah: I don’t believe that because when
I crossed there was no one waiting and I made
it.
And I knew there was no one waiting, in 2015.
Sarah and her sister Yusra first made headlines
in 2015.
After fleeing Syria, they used their swimming
skills to pull their boat to shore on its
journey from Turkey to Lesbos.
They saved themselves and 18 other people
Yusra is now a UNHCR goodwill ambassador and
was on the refugee team at the Rio 2016 Olympics
Sarah won a scholarship to study social sciences
in Berlin but kept returning to Lesbos and
joined a Greek NGO that assists newly arrived
refugees .
I believe when you fear something, you should
just go for it.
I fear the place that I landed in, and I wanted
to be on this ground again.
Following her arrest in August 2018 Sarah’s
classmates campaigned for her release
Florian BeckerDirector, Bard College Berlin
We are extremely relieved.
It was just a beautiful moment to be able
to walk to our cafeteria with Sarah knowing
that everybody was going to be waiting there.
But Greek authorities claim Sarah was part
of a criminal network.
She is currently awaiting trial
The experience in general has given me this
traumatizing fear.
I am afraid I am not gonna get my freedom
back.
Because even if I am outside I am still under
trial.
I still cannot go to the place that I love.